it's the jewel in uefa's crown its
biggest money spinner
but the champions league is now under
threat from a breakaway super league
uefa has reacted with fury to the
proposals
saying enough is enough and adding
the club's concerned will be banned from
playing in any other competition at
domestic european or world level
and their players could be denied the
opportunity to represent their national
teams
a breakaway league of europe's top clubs
has been rumored for a while
but the plans have never been as
advanced as this
financially backed by the u.s investment
bank jp morgan
[Music]
the league will be formed of 20 clubs 15
permanent who can't be relegated
and five that earn their place on merit
games would be played midweek
first in two groups of ten the top three
from each would then go through to
knockout rounds to determine the winner
[Applause]
juventus president andrea agnelli has
been one of those behind the proposals
even though he sat on uefa's board
if there is interest by these kind of
players by these financial institutions
it means there is a potential for a
bright future
within our industry there's been
widespread backlash to the plans
with fans calling it a greedy power grab
it's terrible it's like just greed
taking over really don't think about the
fans like
our fans have traveled to all the games
right as well i like keeping the status
quo i think things work
relegation and promotion are good things
they
provide competition sounds motivated by
money by greed which
is not a good thing to be in the game
anyway uefa won't want to give up on its
cash cow without a fight
but the super league is digging in
reportedly launching legal action to
stop moves from blocking the league's
formation
well let's hear more now on the super
league from a super fan the executive
director of the group called football
supporters
europe ronan ivan ronan a very warm
welcome what do you make of some of the
best european clubs playing each other
on a regular basis because i imagine to
some fans the super league might sound
like a dream
i don't know if it sounds like a dream
for a lot of fans it certainly sounds
extremely boring to a lot of others
the the beauty of the european football
is about its diversity and what we're
seeing now is the concentration of
of wealth power and the top of the game
in the hands of a few clubs
that are currently spread over three
countries they might be three
four five six in the end uh when the
project is launched but
uh yeah the idea is to concentrate uh
the the elite of european football into
the the hands of
of a few clubs of a few investors and
just a few um
western european countries so in the end
this will make european football
less european and it will shrink into
yeah just
the hands of your clubs in the united
states as you know there are also
uh close leagues like the uh uh um
proposed super league like
the american footballs nfl and the nba
for basketball for example
both are really quite successful uh with
huge fan bases
why can't this work as well yeah they're
successful but they're very different
the the the fun culture in in northern
america is very different to what we
know in europe
the legal framework as well the economy
of the sports and what fans
are ready or able to spend into into
football and other sports is extremely
different as well
in europe versus northern northern
america
i think what we're seeing here as well
is the number of clubs that wants to to
have the cake and eat it too
they are they want the comfort they want
the security of the franchise system
but without the strong regulation that
we see in northern america haven't seen
anything in what was published yesterday
that
lean into into
highly regulated system as the as the
northern american one
so they want the security they want
the private uh the private competition
but without any form of strict
regulation
why are german clubs like bayern munich
and dortmund and also french club
paris saint-germain staring clear of
this at least for now
yeah it's a good question i think
they're the best place to answer it
the big difference between the german
and english clubs for example is that
the german won some member run so
uh i think there is still a hope in
in german football and a power in the
hands of the of the fans of the members
of the club
that represent a real counter power uh
in this in this
uh discussion as for france it's
it's interesting that paris is clearly
psg is clearly dissentating itself from
from this
it might have to do with the fact that
uh the qatari uh investors are not in
in not in this for for the money it's
it's about it's about public relations
it's about international politics
and as things stands with the with the
heavy
political backlash against uh against
the superleague project
they would clearly not benefit from from
joining the super league so at this
stage
they are staying on the side of the
sports governing bodies and the public
institutions will see where things
go in the near future all right head of
the football supporters
europe ronan yvonne thank you for
joining us
thank you